Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Il y a au fond deux existences
et deux manières d’exister.
Il y a nos existences individuelles,
celles de chacun d’entre nous,
de notre famille,
de notre cercle élargi d’amis.
Il y a un sujet plus compliqué à aborder,
qui est celui
de nos existences collectives,
et notamment notre existence
collective à travers un pays.
Et c'est difficile, notamment en France.
Je vous le dis,
comme correspondant étranger,
tout en étant franco-suisse,
quand je regarde la France, il y a
un mot qui revient en permanence.
Je suis sûr que vous l’avez entendu, que
vous l’avez lu, peut-être même ce matin,
c’est le mot de « fracture ».
À entendre les médias,
la France est totalement fracturée,
les fractures au pluriel sont
en train de disloquer le pays.
On a même l’impression qu’il y a parfois
plusieurs pays qui se regardent
et qui ne se comprennent pas.
Au fond, l’existence de la France,
à en croire ce qu’on lit parfois,
elle serait en péril
à cause de ces fractures.
Ce mot-là, je le trouve
extrêmement pesant -
je ne sais pas pour vous -
parce qu’il signifie d’abord blessure.
Une fracture, c'est une blessure.
Il signifie que ça vous est tombé dessus.
Au fond, qu’il n’y avait pas
de manière d’y remédier.
Ça fait très mal, une fracture.
Ça peut être réparé,
mais ça peut aussi vous laisser handicapé,
et handicapé durablement.
Moi, je vais vous parler d’un autre mot
et pour ça je vais puiser dans l’Histoire,
dans l’histoire avec un grand H,
c’est-à-dire dans l’histoire nationale
que j’ai essayé de regarder
avec cet œil un peu étranger.
Le mot en question,
c’est le mot « démarcation ».
Démarcation, c'est un mot aujourd'hui
qu'on n'utilise presque plus.
On l’utilisait encore beaucoup
jusque dans les années 70
parce qu’il faisait
référence à cette ligne
qui, normalement, devrait apparaître.
Voilà.
Elle est ici.
La ligne de démarcation, vous en avez,
j’imagine, entendu parler.
Les plus âgés d’entre vous
peut-être plus que les jeunes.
C'était au fond la cassure suprême.
Vous vous demandez :
« Pourquoi nous parle-t-il de la ligne de
démarcation qui séparait la France en deux
entre l’armistice du 22 juin 1940
et l’invasion de la zone dite libre
par les Nazis en novembre 1942 ?
Il y avait à ce moment-là deux France.
Et ce qui m’a passionné comme journaliste,
c’est : « Qu’est-ce que
cette ligne de démarcation dit
de la capacité de la France à survivre ? »
Je vous la fais courte
et il y en a peut-être parmi vous
qui sont historiens et qui connaissent
cette histoire encore mieux que moi.
Le 22 juin 1940,
lorsque l’Armistice arrête les hostilités
entre la France et l’Allemagne nazie -
on peut dire -
le pays n’existe plus.
Le pays est à genoux.
Au fond, ceux qui aujourd’hui nous disent,
et ils sont assez nombreux,
que la France est menacée de disparition,
eh bien, ils en avaient
l’illustration concrète
en 1940, avec cette ligne
que les généraux allemands -
figurez-vous, les généraux nazis -
désignaient comme le mors -
un mors comme le mors d’un cheval -
le mors dans la bouche de la France.
Vous voyez la forme de cette ligne ?
Évidemment, en la regardant,
vous comprenez
pourquoi elle était tracée ainsi.
Toute la façade atlantique était bien sûr
une zone aux mains de l’occupant,
parce qu’elle était stratégique, y compris
la région dans laquelle nous sommes.
Puis, au niveau de la Touraine,
elle piquait vers l’Est jusqu’en Suisse -
d’où mon intérêt -
laissant au Sud des zones
essentiellement rurales,
ce qu’on appelle aujourd’hui
la « Diagonale du vide ».
Vous avez dû entendre
peut-être cette expression.
Toutes ces régions, ces contrées rurales,
qui se sentent abandonnées.
Au Nord, les zones plus industrielles
sur lesquelles, évidemment,
l’occupant voulait mettre la main.
J’ai eu cette idée de suivre
cette ligne de démarcation,
de partir du Pays basque,
de la suivre jusqu’à la Suisse
en plusieurs tronçons.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ça s’appuyait
sur une histoire personnelle.
Il se trouve que je suis franco-suisse,
que ma mère est française
et que j’ai grandi
dans un petit village de la Nièvre,
en plein centre de la France,
au pied de la ligne de démarcation.
La Nièvre ne faisait pas partie des
départements coupés en deux par la ligne.
Treize étaient coupés en deux,
la Nièvre n’en faisait pas partie,
mais la ligne de démarcation passait
pile au sud du département
et elle était matérialisée
à cet endroit par une rivière, l’Allier.
Cette ligne avait pour particularité
qu’elle avait été tracée très vite
au moment de l’armistice du 22 juin 40.
Elle empruntait tantôt des routes,
dont certaines existent encore,
des tracés en forêt,
des chemins forestiers,
des rivières et, quelquefois, elle
était matérialisée par des barbelés
dans des zones qui avaient été, je dirais,
coupées en deux
spécifiquement pour la ligne.
Sur cette ligne de démarcation, vous aviez
partout des ponts
qui permettaient de la franchir
aux endroits où elle était
matérialisée par une rivière.
Pourquoi j’ai décidé
de vous parler de ça ?
Parce que ça prouve beaucoup de
l'existence collective de la France.
En tout cas, c'est mon avis.
On dit que la France aujourd’hui -
c’est un autre terme très utilisé -
est un archipel.
Qu’est-ce qu’un archipel ?
Il y a des archipels immenses,
comme l’archipel indonésien par exemple.
C’est un chapelet d’îles
plus ou moins importantes,
assez peu souvent reliées entre elles,
quelquefois très éloignées,
et qui ont une caractéristique,
c’est d’avoir une population
extrêmement diversifiée
qui sont des ensembles souvent difficiles
à tenir au sein d’une même nation.
Donc l’expression « archipel »
est très, très lourde.
Elle voudrait dire que ce territoire-là,
tout à fait cohérent,
serait devenu un chapelet d’îles
qui ne se parlent plus
ou qui ont des difficultés
à vivre ensemble.
Moi, je suis persuadé du contraire.
Je suis venu vous dire
que l’étude de la ligne de démarcation,
avec toutes les horreurs qui furent celles
de cette période et celles de cette ligne,
l’histoire de la ligne de démarcation
prouve exactement le contraire.
Pourquoi ?
D'abord, il faut savoir une chose.
Et en ce moment, en cette période
où on a une guerre
à quelques milliers de kilomètres
de La Baule,
il faut savoir d’abord qu’il y a et qu’il
y aura toujours dans toutes les guerres
une proportion incompressible de salauds.
C’est comme ça, dans toutes les guerres.
Les salauds de cette guerre-ci,
la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
de la ligne de démarcation,
ceux qui opéraient le long
de cette ligne, on les connaît.
Il y a eu quantité
de documentaires sur eux.
Ce sont ceux qui dénonçaient
les fugitifs à l’occupant, à la Gestapo,
ceux qui dénonçaient les passeurs
qui justement convoyaient les gens de
la partie nord occupée vers la zone libre.
Ce sont ceux qui aidaient carrément les
Allemands, au fond, à asservir la France.
Ceux-là,
encore une fois, tout ce qu’ils
ont fait a été beaucoup détaillé.
Et c’est évidemment impardonnable.
Dans beaucoup de cas,
ça a été jugé après la guerre.
Et puis il y a tous les autres.
Ce qui est frappant dans ce pays,
la France,
où l’on n’a de cesse
de dire qu’il se disloque,
qu’il est menacé, qu’il se désagrège,
c’est que quand vous regardez
de près cette période,
cette période où,
encore une fois, tout était prêt,
tout était disponible
pour faire disparaître la France -
il y avait une occupation militaire,
il y avait une idéologie,
il y avait même
dans le livre « Mein Kampf » de Hitler,
un plan tout à fait désigné pour faire
de la France, en gros, un pays agricole
avec des femmes reproductrices.
C’est exactement écrit dans « Min Kampf ».
Tout était prêt
et rien de cela ne s’est passé.
Bien évidemment,
il y a la conjoncture mondiale.
Il y a eu la guerre mondiale
que l'on connaît.
Mais il y a eu autre chose.
Il y a eu le fait que
tout au long de cette ligne,
quantité de gens, des milliers,
des millions de gens,
qui normalement n’auraient eu
aucune raison de sauver le pays,
l’ont sauvé à leur manière
en étant les passeurs,
les maillons indispensables,
d’une France qui tient debout.
Et là, je ne vais pas parler
des résistants militaires,
ceux qui ont risqué leur vie, ceux qui
ont pris les armes contre l'occupant.
Parce que sur ceux-là aussi, beaucoup
a été écrit et on est très documenté.
Ceux dont on ne parle pas,
ce sont les anonymes.
Ce sont ceux dont l’existence,
finalement, aurait dû être
oubliée -
et d’ailleurs, elle l’a été -
mais qui, tous les jours, ont fait
passer des gens à travers cette ligne.
Vous savez, au moment du Covid,
on le sait tous, on a eu,
notamment au début,
cette période d’applaudissements
tous les soirs,
où d’un seul coup, la France,
soi-disant en mauvais état,
se mettait à être de nouveau ensemble.
Vous l’avez sans doute fait,
moi, je l’ai fait au balcon,
applaudir des soignants
qu’on ne voyait pas,
qui étaient loin, dans les hôpitaux.
Mais c'était une manière de saluer
un effort national de résistance.
Là, il n’y avait pas d’applaudissements.
Il y avait des gens, des paysans, des
agriculteurs, des ouvriers, des cheminots,
des jeunes femmes parce qu’elles étaient
moins inquiétées par l’occupant,
qui utilisaient leur bicyclette,
voire leurs sous-vêtements,
pour cacher des messages d’une part
à l’autre de la ligne de démarcation.
Il y a eu quantité de Français,
que normalement les circonstances
auraient dû diviser,
qui sont devenus les passerelles,
les ponts, sur cet archipel
afin de le faire tenir debout.
Je vais vous raconter deux exemples.
Le premier se passe dans une ville
pile au centre de la ligne de démarcation,
que vous connaissez peut-être,
qui s’appelle Vierzon.
Vierzon est un nœud ferroviaire
important - il l’est toujours aujourd’hui.
Ville du département du Cher.
Eh bien, les cheminots
qui avaient la charge
de ces trains qui venaient de Paris
et qui descendaient vers le Sud,
avaient complètement transformé
les soutes des trains.
Ils en avaient enlevé tous les câbles,
toute la mécanique, tous les engrenages.
Ils s’étaient arrangés
pour reconditionner les moteurs
et les roues des wagons
afin que dans les soutes,
des gens puissent trouver place,
allongés bien sûr,
sous le plancher des wagons.
Pour que des fugitifs, des pilotes alliés,
des Juifs évidemment,
puissent trouver place et franchir
cette ligne de démarcation.
Une autre histoire à Bléré,
plus près de Tours,
au moment où la ligne fait justement
un coude pour se diriger vers l’Est.
Là, il y avait des passeurs
qui ont enfoui -
d’autres l’ont fait à d’autres endroits -
leur barque dans la vase
pendant la journée
pour franchir la rivière
à cet endroit - c’était le Cher.
Ils enterraient littéralement les barques.
Ils les déterraient pendant la nuit,
faisaient passer la rivière,
et les enterraient à nouveau afin
qu’elles ne soient pas découvertes.
Voilà ce genre d’actes qui fait
que la France a tenu.
Est-ce que l’histoire est nécessairement
pertinente au regard de l’actualité ?
Le correspondant étranger que je suis,
quand je vois le tumulte ambiant,
je me dis que quand même,
oui, c’est pertinent.
Parce que ce n’est pas
seulement un message
du passé qui nous est renvoyé,
c’est un message au présent.
C’est-à-dire que, à un moment donné,
si l’on a peut-être le courage,
mais simplement le réflexe -
et on pourrait y réfléchir
ensemble maintenant -
si on a juste le réflexe de se dire
que la ligne qu’on a tracée,
celle qui est là sous mes pieds,
vous voyez ?
Le cercle rouge, et de l’autre côté,
c’est le plancher noir.
Si on a le réflexe d’oser le franchir,
de faire lien au moment
où tant de choses nous séparent,
y compris en 1940,
je le rappelle quand même,
une armée d’occupation qui pouvait
tout simplement vous tirer dessus,
vous déporter, vous arrêter,
voire vous torturer.
Eh bien, si on a ce réflexe, c’est à ce
moment-là qu’un pays tient debout.
Et dans ces moments où la France
donne l’impression de tanguer
pour plein de raisons
qu’on ne va pas évoquer ici,
je crois que le message
de la ligne de démarcation,
c’est de dire qu’à chaque fois
qu’il y a une démarcation,
qu’il y a une fracture.
C ’est aussi une invitation
à se poser la question :
finalement est-ce que l’obstacle
que nous avons devant nous,
il est vraiment infranchissable ?
Est-ce que les obstacles qui nous séparent
sont vraiment infranchissables ?
Cette ligne de démarcation,
pour moi qui ai visité
tous ces musées de la Résistance,
qui ai longuement regardé
cette série télévisée,
qui s’appelle « Un village français »,
qui raconte toute la période
de la France sous l’Occupation.
L’enseignement
de cette ligne de démarcation,
c’est que c’était aussi
une ligne d’union et de fraternité,
de petite fraternité, loin de Paris,
loin des grands principes,
de gestes qui font qu’on vit
ensemble, qu’on reste ensemble
et que dans la tourmente, on se bat
pour ne pas être disloqué.
Voilà le message de ces 1200 kilomètres
que je vous recommande à tous, un jour,
non pas de faire dans leur totalité,
mais arrêtez-vous dans ces parages.
Vous avez le tracé ici.
Il y a dans un certain nombre
de départements des marqueurs
de cette ligne de démarcation.
Ils sont toujours accompagnés
de petites stèles
en hommage aux passeurs qui ont péri,
qui ont risqué leur vie pour d’autres
que très souvent ils ne connaissaient pas.
L’invitation d’aujourd’hui,
c’est de franchir ces démarcations
et de se dire que
lorsqu’il y a une démarcation,
c’est un défi qui s’adresse à nous tous
et peut-être aujourd’hui un défi
qui s’adresse à la France,
celui de rester debout et ensemble.
(Applaudissements)